this is the most important piece of
equipment in motion pictures the camera
one of the most intricate and sensitive
of all mechanisms its function is to
transform lifeless film flowing through
it at the rate of 24 exposures a second
or ninety feet a minute into the moving
images which you Altima tusk reen that
it does so with high artistry and
effectiveness is view entirely to the
great creative and scientific abilities
of one man he is a man whose skill and
knowledge contribute much to the success
of screen actors and actresses and one
on whom producers and directors rely to
crystallize unfilmed all of their own
artistry and talent this is the man the
director of photography the motion
picture camera man his importance and
influence are felt from the moment of
motion picture begins to take shape
until it is completed it is on the basis
of what his camera can and cannot do
that screenplays are written it is with
an eye to what is expensive to
photograph and what is not but budgets
and breakdowns are prepared it is with a
sound conception of how they will look
before the critical eye of his camera
that costumes are designed and makeup is
applied he checks the dressing of sets
and on through a long list of other
production operations on the
cinematographer then rests the
responsibility of integrating and
translating to film all the many and
varied tangibles and intangibles which
go into the making of every motion
picture it is a responsibility for which
he is well qualified his background is
one of much study training and
experience he has served a long and
thorough apprenticeship in all phases of
cinematography
a progressive apprenticeship which took
him through many stages as an assistant
cameraman and later as an operating
cameraman all long before he reached his
present status as a director of
photography ASC the letters identify him
as a member of the American Society of
Cinematographers just as in Britain BSC
designates a member of the British
society of Cinematographers of necessity
he has mastered the many tools of a
complex and demanding art Cameron's a
wide range of many kinds which vary in
scope limitations and operation camera
lenses and filters each with special
characteristics all designed for
specific uses camera equipment a
mechanized army of it giving movement
speed and flexibility to camerawork
lights and lighting equipment large and
small each item designed for a
particular purpose of necessity tool he
has become an engineer and a scholar in
his field for his work embraces skills
and knowledge in many branches of
science and learning it is as an artist
however that the director of photography
is known and his ability rated all of
his training and technical proficiency
mean little unless he can apply what he
knows in terms of creative artistry he
must have a feeling for design and
beauty as well as engineering his sense
of feel must be sound because his
creativeness depends wholly on his
mastery of the intangibles of art on the
set where he brings that mastery into
play he organizes the thousand and one
separate elements of his artistry into a
unified and effective whole to do so he
supervises the workings of a well
integrated team of craftsmen who worked
closely with him to bring to the screen
the high art of cinematography light is
his medium the only one in which he
works and he orders it to his liking
he works with light in much the same way
that a sculptor works using it to mold
each scene so that it will photograph on
film as he sees it in his creative
mind's eye using enough light in a shot
like this to supply current for a city
the size of Muncie Indiana or Hoboken
New Jersey or a game using so little
light that a candle is brilliant by
comparison lighting for drama
lighting for comedy
lighting for romance
hey get this
wherever he works whatever his
assignment the cinematographer the
director of photography has but one
purpose to add to your Lu be going
pleasure by giving you what you want to
see top entertainment in victims
you